ah
[Música]
como todos los 3 de mayo es conmemorado
el día internacional de la libertad de
prensa una fecha que sirve para revisar
y también para analizar el papel de los
periodistas el papel de la importancia
de los medios de comunicación el
pluralismo informativo la seguridad de
los periodistas y las leyes que los
protegen y también que limitan a los
medios de comunicación esta fecha
también siempre trae un debate sobre
todo aquí en américa latina en donde
existen algunos de los peores escenarios
para el ejercicio periodístico y en
donde los medios públicos son muy pocos
rasguñan presupuestos del estado y en
donde los grandes grupos económicos
controlan los medios de comunicación y
en cierta forma también la agenda
informativa en esta fecha la
organización francesa reporteros sin
fronteras mide la libertad de prensa de
180 países o territorios clasificándolos
en una dependiendo de su situación entre
buena a grave veamos entonces por
ejemplo los países con mayor libertad de
prensa el ranking lo lidera por quinto
año consecutivo noruega le sigue
dinamarca suecia estonia y fin como ven
estos cinco países todos son
escandinavos o nórdicos digamos y
estonia es un estado báltico pero pues
todos están en la parte del norte de
europa para destacar la posición número
8 que está ocupada por costa rica que
vuelve a entrar en el top 10 como los
países de mayor libertad de prensa es el
primer país de américa latina y del
continente es el que tiene la más alta
posición cierra el top 10 como ustedes
lo ven el principado de liechtenstein
pasemos ahora a nuestra región veamos
los países con la mayor libertad de
prensa ya lo veíamos costa rica lidera
en la posición número 8 a nivel mundial
de ahí se descuelga hasta el puesto 29
en donde está argentina en el puesto
número 30 esta república dominicana 44
está uruguay y 68 está ecuador esos son
los que sacan la cara por la región
ahora la otra cara de la moneda los
países en las peores condiciones por su
baja libertad de prensa el top 5 nos
lleva a la posición número 45 de un
total de 180 en donde está colombia le
sigue venezuela luego nicaragua en el
160 a honduras en el 165 y cuba es tal
vez uno de los casos más críticos de
latinoamérica es el peor rankeado con el
puesto número 173 pasemos al tema de la
seguridad muy importante en américa
latina' la seguridad para ejercer el
periodismo que es otra de las deudas
grandes que tiene la región el país más
peligroso de la región para ejercer el
periodismo es méxico posición 179 de
ciento ochenta le sigue colombia en el
puesto 160 luego nicaragua y cierra
venezuela este top con el puesto número
pues hoy en el debate de france 24 vamos
entonces a analizar la situación de la
libertad de prensa en nuestra región en
américa latina' también veremos algunos
casos del área internacional y se ha
malinterpretado o desdibujado entonces
los límites de la libertad de prensa
vamos a ver cómo está ese concepto al
día de hoy en pleno 2022 que es libertad
de prensa y por qué es tan difícil
ejercer el periodismo en nuestra región
y porque algo básico como la seguridad
es una deuda pendiente para poder
ejercer el ejercicio o desempeñarse como
periodistas en esta región para analizar
este tema hemos invitado a maría idalia
gómez ella se editará editora jefe del
periódico eje central ellas mexicanas se
conecta precisamente desde la ciudad de
mexico y en río de janeiro está con
nosotros emanuel colombi él es director
regional para américa latina de
reporteros sin fronteras ustedes también
nuestros televidentes hacen parte de
esta conversación de este debate de este
análisis pueden hacer todas sus
preguntas y comentarios lo pueden hacer
a través de las redes sociales estamos
en facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24
sant y luego qué es personal les
recuerdo que nuestra etiqueta es numeral
el debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y preguntas relacionadas con
este tema comienzo entonces por darle la
bienvenida a maría idalia en la ciudad
de mexico
gracias por estar con nosotros en el
programa y quiero como punto de partida
maridalia conocer su balance general de
la región el caso mexicano que ya lo
vamos a ver en detalle que usted debe
conocer muy bien hay casos muy
preocupantes en este país balance
general de este informe de reporteros
sin fronteras y en la situación en
general
muy buenas tardes muchas gracias vemos
que el informe de reporteros sin
fronteras que sigue muy puntualmente lo
que ocurre en la región y
particularmente en méxico desde hace
muchos años y es una gran herramienta
para ir viendo cómo va avanzando se iba
avanzando y en este caso deteriorándose
la situación nos muestra que hemos
empeorado aún y cuando cambiamos de
nivel en cuanto a varios fenómenos no es
porque méxico hubiese trabajado en ellos
sino porque otros países empeoraron en
su situación por un lado y por el otro
es inexplicable el tipo de violencia que
se vive en méxico y donde colocan como
ya ustedes lo mostraban a méxico en el
peor lugar del continente en materia de
seguridad esto nos muestra dos cosas me
parece que no hay un retroceso real en
el tema de la impunidad y que sigue
siendo una puerta abierta para los
ataques y segundo
cada vez está achicando más en nuestro
país en méxico
y
prácticamente en grandes sectores de la
región del continente
el espacio informativo para la sociedad
y eso es lo preocupante y le hago la
misma pregunta a emanuel en la ciudad de
río de janeiro como punto de partida de
este análisis en manuel balance general
de las regiones de los países críticos y
bueno en líneas generales en estos 180
territorios que han sido analizados qué
balance hace usted
buenas tardes a todas y todos gracias
por recibirme buenas tardes para italia
si hoy es un día muy muy importante para
todos los que defienden la libertad de
informar y difundimos una nueva edición
de esa clasificación mundial que viene
con una nueva metodología y unos
movimientos diferentes de los años
anteriores porque determinan
determinamos perdón nuevos indicadores
y una metodología un poco distinta a
nivel general a nivel mundial
bueno se trata de una fotografía que va
y una fotografía que evalúa las
condiciones en las que se ejerce el
periodismo en 180 países
esta nueva edición a nivel general pone
de manifiesto los efectos que
calificamos de desastrosos del caos
informativo que viene de un espacio
digital globalizado y sin regulación que
favorece las informaciones falsas y la
propaganda lo podemos ver en el caso del
conflicto
ucrania es una hora es ahora una pura
guerra de
propaganda en las sociedades
democráticas en el desarrollo de medios
de opinión también al estilo de foxnews
en eeuu y la generalización de los
circuitos de la desinformación que son
que es impulsada por las redes sociales
también están provocando un aumento de
las fracturas sociales
así que a nivel internacional de nuevo
observamos una asimetría que existe
entre una parte sociedad sociedades
abiertas y por otro regímenes despóticos
que controlan en sus medios y sus
plataformas y se libra de una guerra de
propaganda de nuevo esto debilita en las
democracias
arriba ya le voy a dar la palabra para
que empecemos a hablar del caso de
méxico quiero preguntarle a manuel por
esas nuevas metodologías y esos nuevos
indicadores que fueron puestos en uso
para esta para este informe hecho por
periodista por la organización para la
que usted trabaja quiero conocer en
detalle cuáles son los diferenciadores y
esto que les permitió conocer
profundidad si lo comparamos con los
informes anteriores
si de primera cambiamos el número de
indicadores así que tenemos un análisis
que consideramos como más completo con
cinco indicadores que analizan que miden
en el contexto político el marco legal
el contexto económico el contexto
sociocultural y la seguridad del
indicador que mide la nivel de seguridad
de los periodistas en los países que
analizamos y esto nos permite tener una
visión más más amplia porque cuando se
trata de libertad de prensa no es sólo
una cuestión de seguridad obviamente lo
vamos a discutir en mexico el tema
principal y el más preocupante es el de
la seguridad pero también es importante
saber en qué condiciones laborales
trabajan las y los periodistas de la
región cuáles leyes permiten
para el origen el trabajo periodístico o
si así por ejemplo es fácil perseguir un
periodista denunciar un periodista por
difamación mejoría en los país cuál es
el marco jurídico que rige el trabajo
periodístico y también las
infraestructuras disponibles en el
ambiente económico también es importante
porque observamos también en casi todos
los regiones del mundo una
vulnerabilidad creciente
del periodismo que tiene que ver con esa
clase económica y pasamos también por
una pandemia así que es importante
también hablar de la precariedad de las
condiciones de trabajo de la prensa si
más adelante vamos a hablar de ese tema
la pandemia como ha ayudado la pandemia
a la crisis sanitaria a empeorar algunos
casos en la región pasó a preguntarle a
maría idalia en la ciudad de méxico para
que armemos también como punto de
partida una reconstrucción del concepto
porque creo que se ha desdibujado y ya
se tienen como versiones muy distintas
sobre lo que es el concepto de la
libertad de expresión hasta donde tiene
un periodista la libertad para contar
todo lo que quiera contar hasta qué
punto hay leyes que limitan el ejercicio
periodístico cuáles son las barreras que
se tienen dentro de ese concepto de
libertad de expresión
bueno a lo largo del tiempo hemos visto
como también a partir de las posiciones
de poder se va achicando también esos
espacios por ejemplo el punto de leyes
sobre datos personales protección a
datos personales sobre acceso a la
información de documentos se piden más
requisitos se tiene que ser más
especializado se dan una serie de
elementos que solo una dedicación y de
estudio puede permitir al menos en
méxico ese acceso creo que lo central es
es lo siguiente todo aquello que importa
en la sociedad para tomar decisiones
adecuadas en función de la mejor
convivencia y de la democracia es
importante para el periodismo simple y
sencillamente de la forma en que se haga
de manera responsable veraz para servir
a la sociedad no es a la libertad de
expresión no pertenece al periodismo no
no le es un derecho único es un derecho
social al servicio de la sociedad que
ejercen también los líderes sociales los
defensores de derechos humanos y demás
pero el periodismo es el vehículo
perfecto para todo aquello que no es sea
correcto por parte de los del poder
cualquiera que éste sea y que deba ser
conocido por la sociedad para
transformar su realidad y para mejorar
su situación eso es eso es lo que debe
abocarse el periodismo y vemos como las
leyes y además la intimidación y la y la
descalificación desde el poder están
tomando un lugar
muy importante y que está limitando el
ejercicio de la libertad de expresión y
de el derecho a informar
importante esa frase maridalia en donde
específica usted que la libertad de
expresión no es solamente exclusiva el
periodismo es un derecho que tenemos los
ciudadanos en nuestras sociedades
emanuel su opinión sobre este tema
pues sí les les puedo dar la definición
que nosotros determinamos justamente en
el contexto de esa clasificación para
reporteros sin fronteras la libertad de
empresa es la capacidad de los
periodistas como individuos y colectivos
para seleccionar producir y difundir
noticias de interés público
independientemente de la interferencia
política económica legal y social y en
ausencia de amenazas a su salud física y
mental bueno esta será la definición que
manejamos ahora yo creo que en el
momento que atravesemos y de nuevo
hablando un poco de la de la pandemia el
derecho de informar nunca ha sido tan
importante y durante los peores momentos
de la pandemia el derecho de informar
era tan importante como el derecho a la
salud o sea que la información es pueden
salvar vidas
hemos observado en unos países de
américa latina por ejemplo en brasil o
en venezuela a los mandatarios personas
electas los presidentes incluso
difundiendo noticias falsas
el tratamiento
de coronavirus
discursos públicos
reforzados por publicaciones en redes
sociales de entidades públicas que
estaban haciendo por ejemplo la
promoción de la cloroquina que nunca ha
sido comprobada como eficiente contra el
colon hábil o sea en los y las
periodistas tuvieran durante este
periodo tan complejo que de una
protegerse y seguir trabajando en
entornos tóxicos pero también desmontar
las narrativas de los propios gobiernos
que estaban difundiendo desinformación y
en ese caso desinformación puede costar
vidas os estamos hablando de una
pandemia así que bueno él es la
responsabilidad social de los
periodistas
es fundamental no existe democracia sin
una prensa libre plural independiente y
reforzando creo que la pandemia ha
actuado como un acelerador de la censura
en casi todos los países del mundo
hemos observado muchas dificultades de
acceso a la información pública y ha
sido muy difícil denunciar las
actuaciones de los gobiernos en esa
situación inédita así que claro el papel
de la prensa es aún más importante hoy y
yo diría hoy más que nunca
maridalia nos vamos a meter en un
terreno que usted conoce muy bien y es
el caso de méxico ya lo decía yo de
acuerdo al ranking en términos de
seguridad está en el puesto número 179
de 180 es uno de los países más
peligrosos del mundo
para ejercer el periodismo y el más
peligroso de américa latina' solamente
en el año 2022 han muerto ocho
periodistas han sido asesinados desde
que andrés manuel lópez obrador llegó al
poder al menos 33 periodistas han sido
asesinados en méxico y ya este año se
perfila como uno de los peores para la
prensa mexicana para el desempeño de sus
funciones qué es lo que pasa en méxico
porque no hay cuidado a los periodistas
porque el gobierno hace tal vez
oídos sordos a los reclamos a los
pedidos de los periodistas se le reclama
mucho al gobierno que preste más
atención a la situación y luego ya
hablaremos de la impunidad que lo quiero
en un análisis aparte
un punto de partida que nos podría
explicar lo que no ve el gobierno es
ellos enfocan a que todos los crímenes o
ataques a periodistas son cometidos por
grupos criminales y por tanto no son
responsables del estado no es
responsable y entonces se lava las manos
diciendo que no es el estado el que está
cometiendo estos actos sólo que les
falta un pequeño tramo en esta en este
elemento que si es responsabilidad y
responsabilidad del estado garantizar
que se puede informar de manera libres
eso es lo que no está ocurriendo no
existe la seguridad para que se puede
informar de esta manera de manera libre
de manera veraz y de manera oportuna
luego entonces está fallando el estado
aún y cuando los principales atacantes
que están asesinando en méjico a
periodistas son estos grupos de poder
estos grupos fácticos que están tomando
el control de regiones de manera de
manera de manera diversa y lo que más
desean es acallar desde grupos políticos
con poder a grupos criminales también
con mucho poder y también grupos
económicos dígase como
empresariales locales con algún tipo de
interés también político eso es lo que
pasa entonces es que el gobierno solo se
cree
responsable de investigar estos crímenes
no de proteger y de garantizar el
primero que sea que se haga este
ejercicio de manera real y posible y se
puede informar de todo pero hay otro
elemento que ya se ha abierto una puerta
desde desde los discursos que se dan en
palacio nacional y ya se han reproducido
en gobiernos locales sobre el
descalificar el trabajo periodístico
acusar
también a estigmatizar al periodismo y
eso por coloquen mayor fragilidad el
trabajo informativo de cada uno de
nosotros como reporteros y reporteras de
cada uno de los integrantes de los
medios de comunicación y de los diversos
medios de comunicación es abrir una
puerta
desconocida que hace más factible estos
ataques y
que también provoca una escalada en
donde no se investigan a fondo y si bien
ahora hay más investigaciones con más
detenidos no se dan con los asesinos
intelectuales y no hay sentencias
definitivas entonces que tenemos una
conjunción que se hace en una bomba
explosiva aquí en méxico una bomba
explosiva garantías para informar los
ataques constantes desde el gobierno
para descalificar y acusar a los
periodistas y la impunidad en resumen
estos puntos claves de la situación en
mexico emanuel en qué momento méxico
empezó esta espiral de detrimento de las
garantías de ejercicio periodístico es
algo que ustedes han venido notando a lo
largo de los años que se puede hacer
para evitar que esto escale que haya más
asesinatos ya hay organismos como human
right watch que han pedido al gobierno
mexicano proteger a los periodistas que
refuerza el mecanismo de protección a
los periodistas
ya vemos cómo es la relación entre la
prensa y este gobierno de andrés manuel
lópez obrador en particular
esto
yo diría que hace por lo menos una
década que estamos observando esos
patrones de violencia y de nuevo es
importante insistir que más se matan más
periodistas en méxico que en el país es
oficialmente en guerra o sea el inicio
de los preventivos estuvimos durante
casi dos meses un asesinato por semana o
sea son datos escalofriantes que no
observamos en ningún otro país del mundo
y los padrones se repiten porque los que
los los las y los periodistas que son
asesinados solo generalmente casi
siempre
periodistas al nivel local que trabajan
en estados entre los más contaminados
por la corrupción y la influencia de los
cárteles y del crimen organizado
esos periodistas locales comunicadores
blogueros que van denunciando
públicamente
estas conexiones entre la clase política
corrupta y el crimen organizado y que
van a incomodar a los poderes sean
también económicos y políticos locales y
estos son los más vulnerables estos son
los que asesinan en el país y son los
que necesitan más atención porque no
pueden beneficiar de la protección de
grandes redacciones o sea el problema no
es en el distrito federal el problema es
en veracruz el problema es el sinaloa en
tamaulipas donde no tienen casi ningún
tipo de protección
y yo diría que está totalmente conectado
con el tema de corrupción y infelizmente
que hay variedad yo lo apunto
perfectamente hay un problema también en
este gobierno la llegada del presidente
lópez obrador ha generado mucha
esperanza
y realmente pensar pensábamos que las
cosas iban a cambiar que en decisiones
fuertes iban a ser tomadas en lo que
tiene que ver con el fortalecimiento del
mecanismo de protección federal pero
también
la protección de los petistas a nivel
local porque el mecanismo clara no puede
hacer todo así que faltan obviamente
reformas y reporteros sin fronteras
difundió hace muy poco un informe
detallado sobre esto con recomendaciones
al mecanismo faltan recursos humanos
fans serían de citaciones para las
personas del mecanismo claro y bueno y
esto es conectado con
la gran decepción con este gobierno
también viene de este discurso público
estigmatizante si es inaceptable en un
país donde matan un periodista por
semana tener un presidente que sigue
estigmatizando a las y los periodistas
todos los días con ese espacio
maravilloso que es la mañanera esto es
inaceptable porque los ataques del
propio presidente chema en el mundo real
se transforman en ataques más fuertes
maridalia para cerrar este tema de
méxico y pasar a analizar otros casos de
la región que tan fina es esa línea de
esos grupos de poder que usted menciona
los carteles y los crimen los grupos de
crimen organizado que hay en mexico que
menciona emanuel y la relación que pueda
tener con la institucionalidad mexicana
con el gobierno con
incluso hasta una coordinación esto es
una línea muy fina esto es un secreto a
voces como lo ve usted
para poder responder te diré un poco de
historia muy rápida y justo es un
trabajo que me permitió hacer la alianza
de medios mx que hace poco surgió que
son por primera vez una gran alianza de
los medios de comunicación en méxico de
los más
asentados hicimos una revisión desde
1984 hasta la fecha y nos dimos cuenta
al hacer esta revisión porque esos años
porque es justo cuando alguien se
entromete el crimen organizado en la
labor periodística y empieza a cometer
estos crímenes que no eran tan comunes
pero si hacemos un promedio de ese año
hasta ahora vemos que por lo menos en
promedio en méxico han sido asesinados
cuatro periodistas
cada cuatro meses un periodista lo cual
es espeluznante por la cantidad de años
que representa
evidentemente en los últimos años más o
menos desde la época de felipe calderón
esto se aceleró y se aceleró muchísimo y
muy rápido precisamente por eso porque
se la descomposición criminal la
descomposición en la inseguridad en el
país
trabajo a su vez la descomposición
también hacia el estado y la fragilidad
hacia los periodistas ya de hablar sobre
corrupción se volvió un un problema de
seguridad pero también hablar hasta de
casos más sencillos como ataques a
asesinatos de otros personajes o incluso
accidentes automovilísticos porque estos
están involucrados los criminales es
decir el deterioro ha sido tan grande y
tan rápido y tan acelerado y se ha ido
acortando que lo que vemos es que las
instituciones
no tienen la capacidad para resolverlo
porque también han sido
penetradas en corrupción sobre todo las
autoridades locales como lo decía el
jean y también hay otro elemento muy
importante
no se cree necesario que la vida de un
periodista valga lo suficiente y sea
indispensable para el la democracia y
por eso no se investiga y de ahí la
impunidad importante ese punto también
maridalia manuel pasó a preguntarle
ahora por otros casos de la región que
no estamos hablando como el caso de
méxico el tema de seguridad en donde
méxico sale muy mal rankeado vamos a
hablar de otro aspecto diferente que es
precisamente la libertad de expresión la
libertad para la prensa en territorios
como colombia venezuela cuba nicaragua
incluso honduras entra también en este
en este ranking qué es lo que pasa en
estos países vemos que algunos tienen
unos gobiernos un poco más dictatoriales
totalitarios colombia aparentemente es
una democracia consolidada desde el
punto de vista teórico pero pero vemos
los problemas que hay allí un país de 50
millones de habitantes donde hay dos
canales de televisión nacionales donde
la agenda está controlada por estos dos
canales hay muy pocos medios de
comunicación la pluralidad informativa
colombiana
está en un punto
crítico no es un punto para analizar
yo diría que sobre la situación de
columbia y de nuevo estamos analizando
con nuestra clasificación del año
anterior ustedes saben que el año 2021
en columbia decidió muy complicado con
el tema del paro nacional y durante las
protestas en casi todas las grandes
ciudades del país
y registramos
centenas más de 500 ataques
caracterizados contra las y los
periodistas que cubrían las protestas
y los ataques podrían venir tanto de las
fuerzas de policiales de los de los
grupos antimotines pero también de los
propios manifestantes
así que hay también un problema
son un problema en todo el país de
valorización de la importancia del
trabajo de la prensa y la especificidad
de columbia también es la vulnerabilidad
muy fuerte
de los periodistas a nivel local en los
territorios en las zonas fronterizas
donde también igual a méxico no pueden
beneficiar del mismo nivel de protección
y hay una falta también de compromiso
político con el gobierno
de iván duque de reformar los sistemas
que permiten a la prensa trabajar así
que es un conjunto de cosas me me
permitió hacer un pequeño hincapié sobre
la situación de nicaragua que hay que
realmente creo creo es una de las más
preocupantes de la región el año pasado
en el durante el contexto electoral que
ha permitido a tener ortega llegar de
nuevo al poder de manera totalmente
irregular
casi todos los periodistas
independientes de indicara que tuvieron
que salir del país hay una persecución
tan fuerte hay una censura estatal tan
fuerte que es casi imposible hoy
trabajar libremente como periodista en
nicaragua es un desastre y obviamente la
hora organiza la resistencia se organiza
desde fuera del país pero no hay casi
ningún
periódico activo en el país porque estos
son todos perseguidos por el gobierno
que utiliza todas las maneras de
silenciar a las voces críticas censura
administrativa censura judicial
campañas de acoso espionaje a
periodistas absolutamente todo así que
querían este día también solidarizarme
con las y los periodistas de nicaragua
que están viviendo momentos terribles
terribles claro es una situación
complicada ya llegamos a la parte final
del programa me quedan ya unos minutos
para finalizar no quiero dejar de hablar
de
rápidamente maridalia lo que significó
la pandemia kobe 19 para el detrimento
del ejercicio periodístico para la
imposición de censura manuel daba
algunas líneas sobre este tema cuál es
su opinión al respecto
a una cosa antes el continente tiene
estos claros oscuros y lo que ocurre en
un país puede reproducirse en otro muy
rápidamente porque estos ejemplos se
transmiten fácilmente entonces tenemos
que tener una gran alerta respecto a la
pandemia la pandemia puso a prueba los
gobiernos no sólo en materia de salud
sino también en materia de transparencia
y de información y si todavía las
cuentas no están acabadas estamos viendo
cómo se están publicando información de
cómo fueron obteniéndose contratos
multimillonarios de cómo se utilizan
medicamentos que no debieron utilizarse
de cómo no sabemos cuántos muertos
exactamente corresponden a la pandemia y
cómo ésta fue tratada es un tema que
todavía
está poniendo a prueba a los medios de
comunicación en méxico y en todo el
continente en todo el mundo sobre qué
pasó cómo pasó y qué resultados para la
historia reciente van a ver estos
gobiernos denunciarlos a tiempo para los
actos de corrupción pero también los
actos prácticamente criminales que se
cometieron
en méxico hubo un desequilibrio
informativo hubo descalificaciones pero
todavía aún y cuando hayan salido las
primeras publicaciones que ponen en duda
y cuestionen severamente lo que ocurrió
todavía tenemos que perseguir y hacer y
descargar aún aún más lo que ha ocurrido
y no es un saldo pendiente y también
puso en evidencia la algo que se manuel
la fragilidad de las organizaciones
periodísticas y de la capacidad
periodística de cada país porque hubo
que salir hubo que informar incluso en
las peores condiciones en muchos de los
lugares y en muchos de los lados de este
país así fue así fue emanuel otro tema
importante que quiero traer al debate es
el caso de ucrania también lo
mencionaban ustedes al principio del
programa daría para todo un análisis en
cuanto al manejo del discurso la
propaganda política no solamente por
parte de rusia sino también de ucrania
del gobierno del presidente selenski y
también por parte de otros actores que
están involucrados como la unión europea
y eeuu que reflexiona hacia usted estos
69 días que lleva a la guerra en ucrania
en cuanto al manejo de los medios la
difusión de propaganda y el discurso
pues sí como como lo mencioné
rápidamente ya luego totalmente con esas
observaciones de un mundo cada vez más
polarizado y una crisis de confianza
hacia el periodismo lo que está pasando
en el conflicto en ucrania es la
ilustración perfecta de la guerra de
desinformación y de propaganda en lo que
tiene que ver con rusia y no es bastante
nuevo hacer un trabajo de periodismo
independiente y crítico en rusia es casi
imposible
los pocos periodistas críticos o están
en la cárcel o tuvieran que salir del
país así que en el momento en este
momento del conflicto hay aún más
persecución a las voces críticas y hay
palabras que ni siquiera pueden usar los
periodistas en rusia la palabra guerra
por ejemplo no puede ser utilizada por
los y los periodistas que trabajan en
rusia y estamos con reporteros sin
fronteras traseras haciendo trabajo más
y más invisible de apoyo y de asistencia
directa para los periodistas de todo el
mundo o incluso que quieren hacer un
trabajo de información en estas zonas
conflictivas es muy complicado
que faltan recursos material de
protección etcétera pero como usted lo
dijo bien es estamos frente a una a una
guerra de desinformación compañías de
propaganda de ambos lados y es muy
difícil hacerse su propia idea sobre lo
que está pasando
porque justamente los periodistas no
pueden trabajar en buenos consejos y
esto ilustra perfectamente para nosotros
las las tendencias para nosotros ha sido
sumamente difícil informar sobre este
conflicto precisamente por la falta de
fuentes creíbles para contar los hechos
que están sucediendo allí me quedan
pocos minutos quiero hablar del tema en
este tema de un caso destacado de manuel
dejó a maridalia para el final para la
conclusión el caso de costa rica es
número 8 a nivel mundial cayó del puesto
número 5 el número 8 sin embargo está
dentro del top 10 destacado a nivel
continental que hace a costa rica uno
digámoslo desde el punto de vista
latinoamericano un paraíso de libertad
de expresión si lo comparamos con otros
países de la región
bueno para eso es no existen para los
periodistas infelizmente
[Música]
mirando un poco los indicadores
observamos
observamos una de una que existe un
marco legal jurídico o sea un conjunto
de leyes que permiten a los periodistas
trabajar y que permite a los periodistas
no ser perseguidos fácilmente por
personas que se sienten incómodas por
críticas de otra tenemos un gobierno en
este momento con el presidente alvarado
también que respecta a la libertad de
expresión de la libertad de información
y lo dice públicamente y también bueno y
obviamente no es un paraíso porque
durante la pandemia obtuvieron problemas
también de acceso a la información
pública algunas tentativas de
intimidación pero comparando de nuevo
con los vecinos de américa central es
realmente una excepción y si se puede
publicar sobre cualquier asunto hay
también una infraestructuras disponibles
hay un solo económicamente también el
país es menos afectado por por las
dificultades de la región así que es un
conjunto de cosas pero también que
tienen que ver con la postura de las
autoridades el marco jurídico claro
tienen leyes ejemplares que permiten a
la prensa
vamos a decir normalmente pero paraíso
imprecisamente no lo es porque esto no
existe bueno retiro entonces esa
expresión no es un paraíso de acuerdo a
esta explicación que nos da emanuel hago
la corrección me convence su argumento y
para el cierre le pregunto maridalia
sobre lo que puede pasar en la región
que viene no tenemos bola de cristal
para adivinar el futuro de lo que pueda
suceder en nuestra región en este tema
pero para la conclusión que ve usted
para el futuro más muertes de
periodistas más dificultades para el
ejercicio o mejores condiciones
no habría que invocar esas condiciones
pero si es un escenario factible es una
hipótesis
alcanzable incluso que las condiciones
se deterioren aún más por la cuestión
económica evidentemente que también
influye muchísimo que es parte de esta
cadena pero adicionalmente por la falta
de conciencia de los estados sobre la
necesidad de proteger al periodismo pero
de todo lo que tú decías sobre costa
rica costa rica uno de los ejemplos de
que también es una conquista social y
una conquista de los periodistas mismos
ese acceso a la información y esa
libertad que ejercen no a plenitud pero
sí con gran elementos grandes elementos
que luego entonces la buena noticia
sería que esas conquistas en toda
latinoamérica en todo el continente
pueden darse a partir de que la propia
sociedad y de los periodistas sigan
dándole la batalla para no renunciar a
ellas y para seguir abriendo los
espacios de libertad nos falta entonces
muchas batallas por librar maridalia les
agradezco a maría idalia gómez ya de
manuel colombi por haber estado con
nosotros en este análisis en el día de
hoy en el debate de france 24 ustedes
pueden seguir dejando sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]